how effectively is the Chicago statement
on on how effectively is the Chicago
statement being disseminated how rapidly
our University's signing up or or there
a few signed on early in this whole
crisis Purdue they're about ten or
fifteen that have that have endorsed it
or something like it it's not enough to
just endorse something but if you have
leadership that's committed to creating
an open platform in which people can
disagree and and I'm one things very
encouraging I've been invited by a
number of university presidents to come
speak we have all kinds of innovations
at heterodox Academy to foster a more
inclusive climate in which people can
actually engage with difference there's
a lot of interest so I think the
university leaders were very slow to
react they didn't want to alienate
certain factions of students but they're
almost all reasonable people they're
almost all liberal left not a liberal
they're horrified by what's going on
they know they're sitting atop a powder
keg they don't want things to blow up in
their face as happened at Evergreen so
this brings us to our another product
the one that we're most excited by so it
just went online actually today it's
called the open mind platform if you go
to open mind platform org you can find
we've developed an app we have a whole
library of readings and videos we've
developed an app that guides you through
we don't just say here's how to engage
with different viewpoints we start by
saying why is it good and we make the
case that you need this everybody needs
this and too we remind people that were
all basically self-righteous hypocrites
we have quotes from wisdom traditions
around the world and we've all heard
this so just a little bit of you know
you can call it emotional manipulation
if you like but just get people into a
mindset in which they're willing to say
oh yeah whoa you know calm down we're
all we're all too self-righteous here
and then we then we teach them some
psychology about motivated reasoning and
only then do we teach them to engage
with views that are not their own so
we've already run this in about 15 or 20
classes
the results so far look promising that
at the end of it the measures show that
students are more open to other ideas so
the open my platform we think is a tool
that we think a lot of universities are
going to adopt there's a lot of interest
in it and if there's leadership if the
professor's generally do support
viewpoint diversity and open inquiry if
we change freshman orientation so that
students are trained first and foremost
in how to step back give people the
benefit of the doubt the open minded if
we do that first you know that's like
behavioral exposure to some degree right
the idea would be that if you're if
you're afraid or disgusted by something
that you don't understand the
appropriate first treatment first of all
the treatment is necessary because
otherwise you'll you'll isolate yourself
in the ways that you already described
and second that brief exposure voluntary
exposure is going to be the best
curative thing that's the opposite of
the safe space I exactly need to be safe
space the safe space idea is the worst
thing you could possibly do for the very
people yeah exactly exactly I mean a
psychology what you know the psychology
behind safe spaces and microaggressions
it's just the exact opposite of what we
should be doing if we want to create
kids especially black kids gay kids we
mean whatever if you think that they are
vulnerable to more stigma more conflict
if you think that they are vulnerable
that's especially when a safe space will
be temporarily Pleasant but in the long
run bad boys right and that's the
critical issue too with regards to safe
spaces is that they're sacrificing the
medium and long term of the students
well-being let's say to the short term
lack of fear and conflict they're
infantile izing them essentially so yeah
okay so all right so I was thinking
about the the discussion idea I've got a
personality test online now that's based
on this big fire aspect scale but it
might be interesting as something for us
to think about to to find people who are
high in openness and Lowe and
conscientiousness are orderliness and
offer them the opportunity to engage in
dialogue with people who have the
opposite personality traits you know
because well first of all because
they're gonna run into people like that
always write in and and and maybe even
establish
relationship with them inadvertently and
so being able to tolerate that might
give them the kind of insight that you
said you developed when you realized
that the conservative ethos was based on
a reasonable but not complete set of of
beneficial axiomatic presuppositions so